salamalecs
salam aleikum salam alikoum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai choisi la rade parce que ma mère
parle arabe et ma famille aussi en
algérie c'est pour que je puisse des
chiffres et le coran et aussi pour mon
avenir que j'ai envie de venir et
touristique dans les pays du monde arabe
il ya beaucoup d'un fort de mon quartier
qui parle arabe sert allemande a pas
beaucoup de collèges compte ça c'est
cool parce que c'est une fin une chance
de la brande chocolat chocolat alors cet
exercice peut être anodin mais ça va
vous permettre de reconnaître les
différents personnages qui parlent à
mina ou bien habile lorsque je vois
cette hystérisation concernant
l'enseignement de la langue arabe
c'est tout à fait incompréhensible à
l'éducation nationale on n'enseigne pas
la religion on n'enseigne pas l'islam et
ça je vous le dis je suis enseignant
d'éducation nationale je ne suis pas
aimable
j'ai été interpellé il ya quelques
années par des élèves qui sous prétexte
d'apprendre l'arabe se rendaient dans
des écoles coraniques où il entend des
discours parfois douteux et ça m'a fait
réfléchir au fait qu'en 7 avec trois
millions d'arabophones en france la ram
n'était pas représenté dans l'école de
la république et qui avait là un vrai
manque et qu' il y avait un vrai intérêt
à décorer les l'apprentissage de l'arabe
de la religion et d'en faire quelque
chose de très universel c'est à dire
qu'il n'y ait pas que des élèves
d'origine avec des origines arabophone
qui qui qui apprennent l'arabe mais
n'importe quel élève parce que parce
qu'il ya vingt-deux pays où on parle
arabe dans le monde parce que parce que
c'est une langue aider des pays qui sont
en plein développement et que donc il ya
un intérêt évident à l'apprentissage de
l'arabe à l'école pour tout le monde
regarde om beau
voilà où on en est beau je dirais que
plus de la moitié des élèves parlent un
certain dialecte à la maison alors on
dit pas non parce que là c'est le
dialectal
c'est ce que je disais quand tu as un
dialecte à la maison c'est bien mais
photons servir à bon escient faut te
dire que c'est une richesse d'avoir le
dialecte à la maison mais il est un peu
différent de la langue standard en
venant en classe c'est un arabe standard
un arabe qui leur servira dans la vie
professionnelle ou plutôt dans leur
cursus profession vers 6 terre et dans
la vie professionnelle
c'est la langue médiane qui est parlé
par à peu près 500 millions de personnes
dans le monde et c'est la langue des
médias du journalisme de la télévision
des politiques d'als wahab al watan al
wahda lth annaba ce que je vous ai
demandé de traduire
merci mais je parle un peu français
d'accord